hallo mein name ist supernett ich will
kommen heute zu einem neuen video kennt
ja sicherlich alle das fernsehen
falls sie jetzt nicht kennen lebt ihr
irgendwo hinterm mond und ich denke ihr
kennt auch alle die video das ihr jetzt
letzte woche stattgefunden haben was
letzte woche ich glaube ja die video der
jetzt waren ja am freitag und samstag
und den freitag war ich auf den ich hab
sogar schon ein video premiere ist macht
das seht ihr hier irgendwo jetzt mal
eingeblendet also da habe ich sogar
schon über die video des gelabert ich
habe da hat gesagt dass da so ablief und
war nicht da war und die das alles mit
dem city lief und was ich glaube ich
auch gesagt hatte war dass ich an dem
samstag also am zweiten tag ein dreh mit
rtl hatte ihr müsst wissen rtl ist
sender wo im gegensatz zu ard zdf und
anderen ländern sehr komischer content
teilweise gezeigt wird deswegen war ich
eher skeptisch ob ich das wirklich
machen soll weil der sender in meinen
augen keine seriosität ausstrahlt aber
ich fange erst mal von vorne aber wir
hatten vom oktober letzten jahres
oktober 2015 bis märz diesen jahres also
märz 2016 praktikumsphase unserem
studiengang integriert wo wir ein
praktikum bei einem unternehmen machen
mussten bei welchem unternehmen ich das
gemacht habe ist für diese story als
erstmal nebensächlich allerdings hat ein
guter studienkollege von mir das bei rtl
der mediengruppe in köln nummer und er
hat dort ein mädel kennengelernt die
unter anderem auch an meiner uni
studiert und das war irgendwie totaler
zufall ich weiß auch nicht wie sich
kennengelernt hatten aber ist ja auch
scheißegal jedenfalls habe ich dann
irgendwie auch bei der party mit ihm
getroffen und unterhalten und sie meinte
dann halt dass sie bei rtl arbeitet und
ich habe gesagt dass sich youtube mache
und irgendwie sind wir dadurch haben wir
ja da so haben wir uns irgendwie kennen
gelernt das ist eine typische
freundschaft man sieht sich auf einer
party man laut kurzmann hat jetzt nicht
bei facebook das war's mehr hat man im
leben eigentlich nicht miteinander zu
tun dann war allerdings freitag der
video des tag und als ich halt bei dem
video das war habe ich halt die ganze
nicht auf mein handy geguckt weil ich
gegangen werden
fotos gemacht autogramme gegeben habe
auf der bühne bei setra bp und am abend
dann halt an meinem handy und in
facebook und dann sehe ich auf einmal
dass diese person ja der nachricht
geschickt dass ich erst mal sorgt hey
wieso schickt die mehr zu nachricht so
wäre weil ich nichts miteinander zu tun
aber sie hat dann halt geschrieben ich
glaube ich bin ich jetzt einfach mal ein
hey hey nicht wundern ich rufe dich
jetzt an wegen dem dreh für rtl habe der
nummer von patrick hoffe das ist okay
dann hat sich fünf minuten später
angerufen hat mir gesagt jo hier ist ja
ich sag jetzt mal keinen namen du weißt
ja vielleicht dass ich bei rtl arbeite
ich so ja was geht alles klar ist bei
dir und an diese jahr wir wollen beitrag
über die videos machen unbedingt mega
kurzfristig morgen
ich habe direkt an dich gedacht ich habe
etwa so wie das ok ich war jetzt schon
irgendwie bei prosieben im fernsehen bei
tv total mit stefan raab mit dem spiegel
mit spiegel tv hat jetzt schon ein paar
mal was zu tun doch so andere sachen wie
beispielsweise diese völkerball
meisterschaft bei prosieben dann hat das
zdf nun etwas angefragt weil ich mal
eben zum morden dingsbums dings und das
hat mich wirklich immer ultra viel spaß
gemacht muss ich sagen deswegen
weichheit direkt so ok rtl ist jetzt
nicht irgendwie so dass nicht ins
dschungelcamp gehen muss oder so sondern
die wollen wirklich einfach nur für
explosiven beitrag über mich machen und
investition explosiv ist die
lieblingsserie meiner mutter deswegen
habe ich direkt gedacht dass ich
unschuldig wenn meine mami stand also
plötzlich sehen würde da ich halt erst
an dem freitag nachmittag bzw abend mit
ihrer oma telefoniert habe war ja nur
noch der nächste tag der samstag übrig
um sowas zu drehen und ich dann
natürlich das ganze wieder an meinen
manager weitergeleitet der dass wieder
mit ihr abgesprochen bla bla bla bla bla
irgendwann habe ich dann auf jeden fall
am abend den anruf von elia bekommen es
ist mein partner manager bei studio 71
sehr korrekter will er in assisi hat mir
dann auf jeden fall gesagt dass er das
hingekriegt dazu regel mit rtl so dass
es für mich kein großer stress ist und
auch für rtl das ganze irgendwie läuft
dass sie das passend drehen können
senden können eine passende rücklauf
zeit hat so 14.30 mit rtl das interview
sind fast an der arena control
taxifahrers eventuell suizidgefährdete
beinahe konfrontation mit fünf ja also
ich bin natürlich zu spät gekommen zu
dem interview aber das lag wirklich
daran dass der taxifahrer irgendwie
gemeint hat
rollstuhl hinfährt voll eine
einbahnstraße reinfeldt wieder zurück
fährt fast gegen den baum fällig
zigaretten fünf er bremste voll ab und
ist eine andere story darüber könnte ich
auch ein video machen
taxifahrer in köln ist echt krass als
achterbahn fahren im phantasialand rtl
stand da schon die waren irgendwie
glaube ich zu dritt also einmal die frau
die das interview mit mir geführt hat
dann der tontechniker und der mann mit
der kamera die waren auch alle täglich
ultra lädt also überhaupt nichts gegen
euch ich will mit denen dann
reingegangen und haben kurz gesprochen
was wir machen wollen und zwar am
liebsten dass sie mir kurz ein paar
fragen stellen und dann dass ich zu
meinen zuschauern handy und so ein
bisschen autogramm unterstreicht einfach
mit der beitrag ihnen wie cool während
leute die mich kennen wissen dass ich
nicht irgendwie so einer bin und vor
fenski und posierte für bilder und
danach wieder weg gehe deswegen sind wir
halt direkt nach unten gegangen und
haben uns quasi für die leute gestellt
heisst direkt unten war sind halt muss
sich direkten voll viele bilder machen
und vor der tür das war halt gerade
dieser umschwung um 14.30 15 uhr wo die
leute die gerade der räder waren raus
bloß wurde und neue leute rein gekommen
sind das heißt es war halt auch
dementsprechend voll und ich habe mich
dann halt vor den eingang gestellt wo
die leute noch vor den verschlossenen
türen quasi standen und sie könnte die
so ein bisschen so zurückgehalten haben
ich hatte das interview mit der frau
geführt die hat mich ein paar sachen
gefragt sie auch wieder machst du da
schon wer bist du warum willst du das
tutorial warum hast du so weiter diese
typischen stereo oder 15 fragen man halt
gestellt bekommen und dahin wollen die
alten wie sonst haben die ich nach
draußen gehe und dafür bin ich dann halt
nach draußen gegangen hab euch umarmt
hat mit euch fotos gemacht mit euch
bilder gemacht und ich wollte dann
irgendwie wieder rein gezogen weil das
irgendwie alles wieder zufolge wurde sie
zitiert sich wieder beschwert aber
wieder voll viele leute und wolfgang
keine luft bekommen das hätte ich also
weiterhin nicht verantworten können
deswegen habe ich gesagt ja auch freunde
ich gehe jetzt rein ich komme gleich
nochmal raus muss mir erst mal das mikro
abmachen für rtl damit ihnen wie
zufrieden sind sie ich bin dann rein
gelaufen wurde dann von security und in
die katakomben gebracht und habe dort
dann den rtl leuten das mikro abgegeben
und habe sogar noch fotos mit den rtl
leuten gemacht weil eine tante von rtl
noch ein foto mit mir wollte und das war
dann quasi sogar beitrag also ich hab
die dann noch gefragt hey war mir dann
ausgestrahlt
raus will ja wahrscheinlich montag war
explosiv ist muss ja aktuell kommen ist
ja okay das ist jetzt direkt am montag
war echt ne coole sag ich da bin ich
total darüber gefreut dass alles so gut
geklappt hat und das war s dann quasi
erst also gezogen auf die story also
dann ist am samstag halt noch so
weiterhin so alles passiert in dem video
der sauberkeit auch schon im video
gelabert am sonntag ist dann überhaupt
nicht mehr passiert damit quasi nur
gechillt und am montag sollte das dann
um 18 auf explosiv laufen und um 17 uhr
51 habe ich schon von ilja diese sparte
nachricht hier bekommen kapsel sicher
dass es heute auf rtl läuft macht und da
dachte ich mir schon so wenn ihr mich so
fragt dann vielleicht läuft es doch
nicht heute meine antwort ja
sprachnachricht war dann halt mein spiel
voraussichtlich montag 18 uhr struck
auch gerade also auch seines morgen erst
kommt die fräse nicht genau
also die frau zu mir gesagt
voraussichtlich montag 18 uhr ist chil
ich hab es natürlich auch best match at
gepostet ich habe selbst gesagt ihr
freunde schalten alle montag 18 uhr
exklusiv einer ist ein beitrag über mich
da sind vielleicht auch ein paar leute
von euch darin zu sehen weil ich mit
euch alle fotos gemacht hat und die auch
gefilmt wurde blablabla megacool angebot
gefreut es kam nicht erste scheiß aktion
ich habe schon echt viele praktikas in
meinem leben gemacht und zwei davon
waren bei einer medienagentur und bei
einer marketingagentur von einem
automobilhersteller aber das ist quasi
genau das gleiche man trifft sich immer
jeden morgen und bespricht alles das was
am tag passieren soll also was soll
gepostet werden was soll online
geschaltet werden was steht den tag über
an was sind für meetings völlig klar bla
bla bla bla und bei rtl ist es natürlich
genau das gleiche das heißt sie treffen
sich jeden morgen und sagen okay was wir
heute gezeigt was passt heute ist
programm was ist der aktuelle was müssen
leute raus hauen und da haben die bullen
an den montagmorgen beschlossen okay der
beitrag mit luca wert zwar ist sehr
aktuell jetzt weil die videos ist gerade
mal zwei tage her sind allerdings
schalten wir mal lieber wichtigere
sachen und zwar gina lisa hat vor
gericht gelogen
ich will wirklich überhaupt nicht sagen
dass dieser blöde beschissene video days
beitrag von mir wichtiger ist als das
team leader vor gericht gelogen hat es
ist schon wichtiger das zusenden mit
gina-lisa aber ich finde dann könntet
ihr doch bescheid sagen dass ich dann
bei snap chat sage okay freunde es kommt
doch nicht heute sondern dann
wahrscheinlich morgen wurde allerdings
nicht gemacht ich habe dann auf jeden
fall gedacht die meinte montag ist ja
nicht schlimm
vielleicht kommt sie am dienstag am
dienstag kam es dann auch nicht wollt
ihr mich komplett verarschen ich hab
natürlich direkt an den montag haben
dann gesagt im zuge der sendung noch
freunde es kommt doch nicht mehr heute
kommt wahrscheinlich morgen sorry das
jetzt 30 minuten rtl schauen musste aber
hey schaut einfach morgen vorbei da
müsste es kommen ich habe das natürlich
auch über freundin von mir gesagt und
ich hatten rückmeldungen bekommen wie
beispielsweise luca bist du dir sicher
das ist explosiv und exclusiv war ich
raste bald aus gestern schon den ganzen
scheiß geschaut und heute schon wieder
toluca dank die habe ich zwei mal 30
minuten meines lebens verschwendet bevor
ich dienstag wieder temperaturen wollte
von weniger freundes kann doch nicht
heute kommen morgen am mittwoch erst tut
mir leid dass ich euch jetzt zweimal
quasi in das licht geführt habe habe ich
dann erstmal der freundin war rtl
geschrieben kommt der beitrag überhaupt
irgendwann auf rtl die meisten zugehen
würde gestern schon kommen aber selbst
heute wurde der nicht gezeigt hey es
verschiebt sich immer so krass ist noch
mal mega nervig aber ist leider echt
immer so aber er wird ziemlich sicher
noch gezahlt ich dachte ja okay du sagst
mir ziemlich sicher noch ausgestrahlt
der nächste termin mittwoch gewesen dass
er schon vier tage nach dem video der
ist gewesen und drei tage nachdem ihr
gesagt wurde dass er da hätte laufen
sollen am montag dann hat sie mir
allerdings noch geschrieben ich frage
mal gerade nach und 33 minuten später
also er wird auf jeden fall ausgestrahlt
aber es ist noch nicht sicher wann ist
ja schon mal eine schöne nachricht wenn
man hört von einer rtl mitarbeiterin
dass der beitrag wirklich noch
ausgestrahlt wird dann habe ich halt
noch den mittwoch abgewartet und habe
mir extra um 18 uhr frei genommen um ihr
exklusiv anzuschauen und was sehe ich
dafür beiträge der job der bademeister
mensch ist das aktuell das hat man ja
nicht verschieben können da wurde
wirklich gezeigt die bademeister
besoffene leute im schwimmbad an
sprechen ihnen sagen hey sie sind ja
wirklich sehr betrunken soll betrunken
mit ihrer familie mit ihren kinder die
ich lieber york wieder menschen
ich musste mich ganz ganz toll
zusammenreißen dass ich nicht komplett
ausraste ich meine stellt euch das so
vor
ihr habt den übelsten stress bei den
video days und rtl kommt an ein paar
stunden vorher sagt wir wollen unbedingt
diesen beitrag machen ich mit meinem
manager will ich doch wie kriegen wir
das zeitlich irgendwie reingedrückt
machen uns wirklich den übelsten
stressig dieser mega durch neben sonne
totalen bescheuerten taxifahrer der mich
irgendwie halt leben da anbringen an der
lanxess arena machen da den beitrag
fällig ich sage da die ganzen autogramme
abend muster weg gezählt werden nur
damit ihrem bald fertig kriegen also
nichts ging nicht wirklich ultra nett
aber ich verstehe sie die so sicherlich
gezeigt wird
allerdings hatte ich ja immer noch die
nachricht von der studienkollegin also
er wird auf jeden fall ausgestrahlt aber
es ist noch nicht sicher wann und dann
habe ich am donnerstag auf mein handy
geschaut habe um 16 uhr einen screenshot
von elia bekommen von einem chat verlauf
mit einem rtl typen wer seine rtl frau
hey also es hat sich jetzt
herausgestellt dass für den beitrag
leider vorerst doch nicht senden werden
weil gerade andere themen priorität
haben tut mir wirklich leid trotzdem
vielen dank für alles wollt ihr mich
verarschen bademeister der besoffene
leute im freibad an megawatt priorität
da und du kann also dieser scheiß
beitrag ist mir wirklich nicht wichtig
es ist mir scheißegal auf der beitrag
gezeigt worden wäre oder nicht es geht
nur darum dass ich zwei drei mal aufs
netz hat gesagt habe dass der beitrag
kommt dass die rtl einschalten soll ich
habe es freunden gesagt habe es meiner
familie gesagt ja schaltet man ein ich
bin wieder im fernsehen zu sehen bei rtl
18 uhr exklusiv das ein beitrag über
mich über die video des mega cool habe
mir mit meinem manager über den stress
gemacht das wird irgendwie hinkriegen
dass ihr euren beitrag fällig kriegt das
ist das hat nichts mit irgendeiner form
von professionalität zu tun direkte
ansprache an als rtl
wenn ihr so dringend einen beitrag den
wir machen wollen wie so zeigt er ihnen
dann iso haben auf einmal andere themen
priorität denkt doch mal vorher nach und
ich es danach natürlich ist es im
fernsehen unternehmen und ich will
überhaupt nicht passion oder irgendwas
anderes jetzt machen ich finde so ein
bisschen und professionell zu sagen
luca macht das irgendwie möglich daß wir
den beitrag fertig kriegen aber hey wir
zeigen den doch nicht es hat mich
einfach so ein bisschen abgefuckt vor
allem wenn ich euch das nebst gezeigt
habe und selbst gepostet habe und das
per twitter gepostet habe dass ich bei
rtl exclusiv bin ich hab's freunden
familie gesagt und wir wurden was sie an
verrat von euch darüber wollte jetzt
echt gern video machen weil ich das mega
abgefragt hat ich glaube das video ging
jetzt sehr lange ich bin in der raw
dateien bei 36 minuten wenn es euch
vielleicht wurzel gefallen natürlich
immer eine bewertung freuen und wir
sehen uns in den nächsten video
wiederholt rein deutsches